Kei, incredible match, congratulations.
Thank you.
Can you describe your emotions after this big win?
I don't know what's going on.
You know, I was a little bit tired, especially it was my first semifinal in a Grand Slam.
Oh, it's just amazing, an amazing feeling, beating the number one player,...
...and also playing much better than these couple of matches, I'm so happy.
Well, your last few matches went the distance to five-set matches,...
...it's hot today, the conditions are rough.
How were you able to manage it to pull it off?
Yeah, it was really a tough condition today, I always felt a little bit heavy,...
...and humid too, but I guess I love to play long matches.
I hope I can recover well for the final.
How were you able to recover after losing the second set 6 - 1...
...and then win that third one in the tie-break?
What was the difference?
Yeah, he started to play much better,...
...very consistent and really more aggressive,...
...but I try to forget about these first and second set and try to concentrate again.
Kei, you added Michael Chang to your coaching team this season.
What kind of advice did Michael give you,...
...playing in your first semifinal at a Grand Slam?
Yeah, he's been helping me a lot...
...him and Dante communicate a lot...
...and we've been working super well.
That's why I'm here.
You're the first Japanese male to be in a final of a major.
What does this do to you back home in Japan?
I hope it's big news in Japan.
I feel the support from Japan even from the TV.
It's four o'clock in the morning, but I hope a lot of people are watching.
I bet you everybody's up watching this great run.
Kei, congratulations, best of luck in the final.
Thank you.